joining us now from greater southeast
energy hub is peter goody
and thank you for that introduction and
thank you to babe and mitch suffolk and
to all their sponsors for uh organizing
this event today i think it's a great
opportunity to get a focus on business
and a relationship built around how we
take forward
uh suffolk on its net zero journey
before i start and signpost some of the
things that are going on
in
suffolk to support businesses i'd just
like to give you one word and that word
is momentum
now momentum
it's about impetus
moving a body
me
yourself in the audience your businesses
the local authorities ipswich suffolk
the uk the global community we all need
momentum on this zero carbon journey
i think about covid
and i think the couple of things that
covid pandemic has taught me
the first one is around
how important good science is and
secondly how we apply
innovation from that good science the
second thing it's taught me is around
people and how people take that
innovation and that solution
to solve things now we can do that we've
shown that over the last two years
and the zero carbon journey
is a similar thing that we need to get
both
impetus and our bodies moving
so we need momentum
i don't flatter myself that i'm i've got
any more insight to add to the room
and the people that are in this room
today although uh i do have uh some
knowledge of the work that's being gone
going on in suffolk over the last 20
years
but i think back to 1992 in the rio
earth summit
which was the starting point of some of
this momentum
the conference of parties cop
which was initiated following the rio
earth summit in 1992
is now at its latest stage
next month with cop 26 in glasgow
and i look out into the room and i ask
you and i urge you
to use this event
and to use cop26 to give us momentum on
this zero carbon journey so that's my
speechy firing over i move on to the
the really important bits that i'd like
to cover with you today which around the
services available to businesses
whether they're businesses looking to
become more energy efficient
or looking to invest and generate their
own energy
or whether they're businesses that want
to develop the goods the services and
the skills that we need
to move on this zero carbon journey in
suffolk
so
i'm going to name check some
organizations in their own room today
but it's your job not mine to go and
meet them
to talk to them today
to visit their websites to get to phone
them and find out the things that you
need whether you're a small medium-sized
business whether you're a local
authority whether you're even an
individual consumer
get the information you need today to
get that momentum
so that we can move forward so that's my
challenge to you i will be endeavoring
to talk to those organizations as well
and i look forward to those
conversations over the next
four to six hours as long as we we get
to that point today and we will
benefit all that knowledge that we got
in the room
so if i may
uh
i don't know whether the slides are
moving but i'll leave the slides it's
fine um
these are sort of questions that
some of the businesses i've been talking
to
have put to me and i talked to some of
the energy advisors that are here today
that have been supporting local
businesses
the first thing is i don't know what to
do as a small business i i'm too busy
i'm too stressed i've got to keep my
business going
um i'm not
got the time or i don't know where to go
for the information
also is there money available can i get
a grant
now these things
are potentially questions that we can
answer today
thank you
apologies
yeah thank you
so that help is at hand
and hopefully today
we can flag
up the opportunities that are available
to businesses in the location
so to start
if you're a small and medium-sized
business you may think you haven't
started on this journey but you already
have you've just been doing it as good
business practice
a couple of examples of businesses that
i know one was a garage services
servicing cars when the cars come in
they might replace a tyre for the mot
they then decided well while they
replace the tire could we not get the
equipment in to be able to repair that
tyre
so they provide an additional service to
that business to that customer
by changing their business model and
adding something to their business but
they reduce their environmental cost by
reducing waste of throwing that tyre
away they did it as good business
practice they didn't do it because it
was an environmental thing it saved them
money and gave their customer a better
better service second example
is a small business
their roof was leaking so they had
somebody come in
replace their roof but they insulated it
they weren't going to do it but they
decided yeah we'll insulate it
their employees
were so happy with that one action that
business took because it improved the
space they were working in the winter
time when it was cold before it was
warmer and in the summer time it was too
hot so it could kept the building cooler
so two very simple things they weren't
done for environmental reasons they
saved energy they reduced waste but what
they did do was benefit that business in
terms of its
customers
and its employees
now
we're going to focus on two things
um
that really other i would argue the end
point
in terms of benefit
and that's recognition
it's really important that we recognize
good practice
i never
feel comfortable with the word best
practice because that suggests you've
achieved the pinnacle we need to keep
moving on keep that momentum going but
good practice should be recognized and
in suffolk we're blessed
we have a carbon charter
which recognizes businesses that are on
this journey towards zero carbon
and any business that is following that
pathway
can choose to be part of that journey
using the carbon charity as a means of
recognition for their action and to
improve their brand awareness
and to show to their customers and
supply chain that they're serious about
becoming zero carbon
i'm just going to name check
a few businesses
have got calm childhood status
i could go on more than
more than uh you want me to but abc
taxes hold a tree anglia print barn
world print co-op
comes up a dozen or so times in terms of
the actions they've taken in terms of
suffolk carbon charter and taking action
james white drinks lignacite lindsey
lodge farm maple farm midas uk i could
go on and on and i'm sure you don't want
me to but this is a demonstration that
this is not something novel this is
something that businesses are getting on
with
and if you want to be on that journey
and you want that momentum
then the suffolk carbon charter is a way
of demonstrating that and recognizing it
we're really blessed that we're into the
second decade of the creating the
greenest county awards which recognizes
sustainability in the round
it recognizes that households businesses
communities are taking action and
we're blessed that they give
the opportunity for them to have a goal
of evening and some promotion
in suffolk about the things they're
doing so suffolk lagunas county i think
the deadline if you want to get your
nominations is close to play today
i can see some nodding so if you think
you've done some really good work get
your nomination in if you can think of a
business that's done some really good
work get your nomination in
and that would be something that will
give that business all that organization
whether it's community organization
recognition and reward for the good work
now taking a step back
i'd like you
to benefit today from the support that's
in the room not only from some of the
suppliers that are here and thank you
for coming along but two schemes that
are very worthwhile for small and
medium-sized enterprises to get involved
in
the first is the business energy
efficiency anglia scheme b for short
and
i hope one of the advisors will stick
their hand in the air
excellent
go see that gentleman if you're a small
or medium-sized enterprise and you want
to find out how to improve your carbon
footprint your environmental journey
get some momentum onto your improvements
find out about their or their auditing
and their independence and value that
they can add to your business find out
about the grants that they offer you
and get involved and participate and get
supported
the second is eastern new energy
are they in the room today
excellent hi joe
fantastic new scheme providing similar
range of services but if you're say on a
business park or an industrial trading
estate talk to them
they provide
access to expertise and independent
advice
and there's also grants available as
well
they will also support you if you've got
a product or a service that you want to
develop that is a green product
it's an environmental product it's a
product that will help reduce the
environmental impact of an organization
so talk about them about how you could
get your product to market
and i'm sure they can support you
i'm really pleased to be able to name
check those two organizations in
particular
but also talk to the suppliers whether
it's around led lighting boiler
replacement with
heat pumps or any other decarbonized
technology whether it's about insulation
whether it's about
system controls building controls
whether it's around changing motors
in your factory or process equipment
upgrades whether it's installing solar
power
all of these things can be achieved
they may require investment but some of
them are low and no cost options that
will add value to your business
now
i'd like also to finally look at
travel and mobility now if you go onto
the green suffolk website is a great
resource whether you're a householder
community business or otherwise
but go through that website and if your
customers or your employees come to your
your business premises
find out how they can come to your
business permit sustainably
you'll find on the um the greenish
county web the the green suffolk website
uh a web page called suffolk way to go
that will help you identify
walking maps routes for your staff to
walk to work cycle maps
schemes to help link up public transport
provision to allow you and your
customers to get you to your business
and for you to trade in a more
sustainable
way the other area was around
vehicles and particularly with the last
two years we've seen the rise of
home delivery
a lot of vans on the street we've also
heard about the
merging
policy positions around electrification
of passenger vehicles
with
new internal combustion engine sales
being prohibited from 2030
that raises the question around
infrastructure and charging
go and talk to peter here in terms of ev
charging
if you're a business
and you haven't got the capital
peter has it
it's a rental scheme two pounds a day
you can get an install
of an ev charging provision p i probably
dropped you in it you've probably got no
money whatsoever but anyway we'll do
that
use that scheme
to be able to get charging provision
into your business whether it's for your
own passenger vehicles or your white van
you'll be able to not only
charge your vehicle
but deliver savings into your business
okay the capital cost is the biggest
challenge i would argue with regard to
electrification of transportation we can
talk about range anxiety and we can talk
about all of the other issues but it's
the capital
to get you into that place now if we can
make it easier for businesses to get
into that
with no and low-cost capital routes
then hopefully that journey for that
business will be easier giving them
momentum to be able to move into an
electrified transport world
so talk to peter plug in suffolk
and i think with that i've probably name
checked as many as i can think of i'm
sure there are loads more out there but
please network talk to people not today
only but beyond this take it out talk to
your suppliers talk to your customers
find out who else out there wants to go
on that journey and give them momentum
as well
with that thank you
[Applause]
you